-Our next guest
is a very talented actress
you know from
"Parks and Recreation"
and "Girlfriends' Guide
to Divorce."
She stars in "Good Girls,"
which airs Sundays at 10:00 p.m.
here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-We've got the garden hose
the roofing nails,
hydrogen peroxide, Sun Chips
mothballs, duct tape,
yeah, and five bags
of fertilizer.
What?
-[ Sighs ]
These aren't groceries.
-No. It's a mix of sundries.
-Please welcome back to the show
our good friend Retta.
Hello, Retta.
-Hello!
I laugh every time you guy
start on "My Doink Fell Off.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm so glad --
I'm so glad you appreciate thi
piece of fine modern pop art
We're selling the NFT for that
so if you want to buy...
-Is that right?
-Yeah.
If you want to buy
the non-fungible token for
"My Doink Fell Off."
Hey --
-You looking for that cash
-We're getting
pretty close to maybe,
hopefully, fingers crossed
being on the other side of this.
How are you feeling
about your personal readines
to reintegrate yourself
into society?
-Well, I have been practicin
putting my makeup on again
because I 100% forgot.
[ Laughter ]
I've been living that ghoul life
in this house.
But I -- Because
I've been working, at least,
I feel like, you know,
I know how to talk
to humans in person again,
so I got that part covered
Now I just got to figure out
you know,
things to wear in public
and how to do my hair or my --
and my makeup,
and I'll be good to go.
-Now,
we've mentioned this before.
But you -- Before
you were in show business,
you worked as a chemist.
And has this been exciting
watching chemistry
be such a huge part of our lif
this last year
in the creation of
and rollout of vaccines?
-Well, the exciting part i
when people actually believe it.
You're like, "Thank God. You'r
going to get the vaccine."
But I don't believe --
I don't know yet if I'm full
invested in the system of,
you know, giving out the shots
Because everybody's saying
you know,
their appointment was canceled
or they ran out of vaccine
and that sort of thing.
So I don't put my trust
in that system.
I've -- I've gotten vaccinated
and I was lucky enough
to get Johnson & Johnson.
So I don't have to
worry about --
Because that was my fear.
I was like,
"I'm going to be mad
if I get the first shot,
and then I schedule
the second and..."
Because in my head I'm like,
if I don't get it to the hour,
you know, 24 hours within,
it's not going to work.
I know better than that.
-Was it exhilarating?
Did you feel exhilarated
and relief
when you got
your Johnson & Johnson?
-I did. I was --
[ Laughs ]
I had, like, a --
Not that I -- I didn't cry
I got a little, like, misty.
Like, at least
that part is done.
And then I was like --
It was so weird.
I just didn't know how to speak.
And I was like,
"Thank you for helping us!
[ Laughter ]
-That's great.
-Which is like --
-I'm so glad you said that
-Yeah, it was like -- You know
Because, you know,
it's like FEMA.
They came in and saved the city!
It was like,
"Thank you for helping us!
-What did you --
When you were a chemist, did -
did the other people in the la
have any idea
that comedy was in your future
or even a talent of yours?
-Yeah, they knew.
They knew chemistry
was just a holdover.
They -- They came --
They would come to my shows.
It was so, so sad.
Because, you know, the --
when you first start out
in comedy, you know, you'r
not killin' it all the time.
So they would come and sit
and I remember
being so, so nervous.
And I drank a six-pack of --
Uh, what's that Ice?
The first Ice...
-Oh, yeah.
-...drink that came out.
I can't even remember
what it was called,
but it was Something Ice.
-None -- None of the Ices
were particularly good
to drink six of.
-[ Laughs ]
Well, they didn't last, either
And I was --
You know, to calm my nerves.
And it wasn't pretty.
But they were gracious.
And they, you know,
applauded for me.
And I -- I'm pretty sure they're
probably all very surprise
that I was successful
beyond that day.
-Speaking of successes,
we spoke in May.
You mentioned that you
bought yourself a bike,
were feeling a little tentativ
about getting back on it
because it had been a long time.
How have you done?
Have you made any progress
-Two weeks ago was
the first time that I rode it.
-[ Laughter ]
-So, I mean --
My friend bought the -- the --
What's the thing called?
To hold it in place?
-Training wheels?
-[ Laughter ]
-No. Not training wheels.
-A kickstand?
-No, so I can ride it
like a stationary bike.
-Okay. Oh, gotcha.
-No. So --
There's a thing
you put the back wheels in
so that you can ride it
as a stationary back.
-I see. Gotcha.
-So, I've done that a few times,
but this was the first tim
that I actually took it ou
on them streets.
But I took --
I put it in my car,
I took it to my friend's house
so that they could help me
safely get on.
I needed a spotter,
'cause, you know,
I had the knee replacement..
-Right.
-...in November,
so I'm still not steady yet.
So I had my friends spot m
to get on the bike,
and then one rode in front of me
and one rode behind me
so they could keep an eye
on traffic,
and, you know,
everyone yelling, "Car!"
You know, I'm like,
"Is this safe?"
Because I was real scared.
And so I went
last weekend, as well,
and there was only
one friend with me.
So a little more heart racing.
But I succeeded.
And I feel really good.
But I didn't --
What I didn't know
in riding a bike
is how much my arms hurt.
Because they got me
a mountain bike.
-Yeah.
-So I kind of have to hold o
and lean forward.
That's the workout.
-[ Laughs ] Nobody tells you
Nobody tells you about the arms.
-They don't. They really don't
I need a beach cruiser...
-Yeah, you got to get it
up here. I like mine.
I built, like,
one of those standing desk
so I can just be like this
-[ Laughs ]
That's how you're doing it
-Yeah, I can only go straight.
That's the only downside.
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
Congrats on being
back on the bike.
Congrats on the show.
And we always love
to have you here.
-Thank you. Appreciate it.
Good to see you, Seth!
-Good to see you, Retta!
"Good Girls" airs Sunday night
here on NBC.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."